>>Richard: Welcome to this week's Android
Developers Office Hours.
I'm Rich Lyman.
>>Nick: Hi.
I'm Nick Butcher.
>>Richard: You're not Nick Butcher?
>>Nick: I am Nick Butcher.
>>Richard: He isn't Nick Butcher today because
of the Olympics.
It didn't make any sense.
Yeah, welcome to this week's Android Developer
Office Hours.
We're here to answer your questions on Android
development.
If you would like to join in the Hangout,
please just ping on the thread inside the
Google+ or Android Development's plus page.
We'll add you in so you can come and ask questions
on Android development.
Things that we don't talk about in these sessions
are product road maps, future releases, other
things that may be deemed confidential.
It's all about the development and Android
technologies and Android devices, themselves.
Do you have something else to say?
>>Nick: No, you just did it.
You just did it.
>>Richard: I'd like to welcome Al Sutton back
in again.
He's definitely our most regular attendee
of these Hangout sessions as well.
>>Al: Hey, guys.
>>Richard: Hey, Al.
I should open the chat window 'cause I'll
often post the most useful links in that as
we're running through.
We have some viewers on YouTube already.
So, I guess--.
>>Nick: Well, anything interesting going on
in the world of Android you want to talk about
there before we start the meeting, Al you
mentioned that some cities are offering something
interesting for developers?
>>Al: Yeah.
They're offering a remote testing lab, which
you can sign up to and you can get a lot of
access to devices like the S3 Galaxy Note,
even S2's, Tabs 10.1, just to test out your
applications remotely.
So there might be some developers who wanna
play around with the S3 because it's, they
were saying they sold ten million now.
So it's well worth trying out apps on it.
From what--.
Ten million.
From what I can see, you get a number of credits
assigned to you and you can book a 15- or
30-minute slots and use that device as you
want.
>>Nick: So, much like Testdroid or the cloud-based
testing solution you've seen before, but it's
the free set and just handset devices?
>>Al: Yeah.
It looks like, from what I've seen, they give
you a certain number of credits.
You can probably buy more credits if you want
more time.
But you get a certain number of credits, which
I think works out about four hour's worth
of testing on any device that they've got
in their system.
And looking through it, they've got S3s, Galaxy
Note, Galaxy Nexus, the original Galaxy S,
S2, Tab10.1, various variants even going back
to the original Galaxy Tab 7.0 oh.
So--.
>>Nick: Well, that sounds quite reasonably
high-end.
What about the lower end stuff?
I think those are often the ones which might
pull up some nibbles on certain apps, like
the Galaxy Y and Ace and this smaller, lower
end devices.
[inaudible].
>>Al: It seems more focused on the premium
offerings.
The Galaxy S, I suppose, is what you could
class the lowest it appears to go to, even
though it's what's high end a few years ago.
It's a WVJ device, so it gives you that 800
by 480 screen in most of the things you'll
see.
But there's a limited selection at the moment,
but it does, it very much seems to be the
higher end offerings.
>>Nick: And what's the URL to that?
>>Al: [inaudible].
>>Richard: Yeah.
Create your account there and let's go and
have a look at the test lab.
We get asked a load of physical devices over
the web.
>>Nick: That's cool.
I think Sony, well, nee Sony Ericsson, now
Sony Mobile, I think they're called, offers
something similar.
I think they have physical--you can basically
borrow devices.
>>Richard: There's a bunch of other third
party solutions that we could mention as well
that have a variety of handsets.
Usually, they're not free.
I heard that Samsung is gonna be free for
Samsung developers, which is excellent.
You just book your time slot and get your
device.
>>Al: And the fact that they're carrying ten-inch,
seven-inch, and four-inch and down to, I think
four inches is as low as they go.
That means you can also cover a range of sizes
if developers haven't got access to tablets
and stuff like that.
It's pretty cool.
>>Nick: That's cool.
>>Richard: Cheers for [inaudible].
>>Nick: Well, you know, the emulator gets
you a lot of the way of the screen-size testing,
but it's often OEM customizations.
So, if you do something with a camera or something
like that, when real devices can come in real
handy for the testing.
>>Al: Yeah.
>>Richard: Yeah.
>>Nick: I guess that's really helped out some
people.
So, yeah.
Well, thanks for bringing that up.
That's an interesting topic.
>>Richard: OK.
So, we'll head into the moderator.
I've put the moderator link for the question
for today inside the Google+ post as well.
I was hoping you could see that.
It's also at developers dot Google dot com
forward slash live forward slash Android,
where you can track these events going forward.
We actually have three sets of Office Hours
the following Wednesday.
One in the Asian time zone, one in European
and one in the America time zone.
So, you can either switch to watch it during
work or after work, whichever suits you.
>>Nick: Or, if you're super keen and do the
triple, you win some kind of prize maybe?
>>Richard: But if you ask the same questions
in all three, then you lose the prize.
[laughter]
Just trying to see if you can get three different
answers out of three different sets.
>>Al: There is no prize.
>>Richard: There is no prize.
[inaudible].
So, onto the moderator.
"Hi," says someone.
It's up there.
"A friend of mine has created his IOS application
and he wonders what ways are available to
convert it to an Android application."
>>Nick: What is this IOS?
>>Richard: IOS?
I-O-S.
Other products.
>>Al: I think it runs on Cisco routers.
>>Richard: He's created a mobile application
for a platform and would like to bring it
to Android.
Maybe he don't want--.
>>Nick: Is that Stockholm Syndrome?
[laughter]
>>Richard: So, I mean, the thing is to become
an Android developer, really.
We don't charge you to get hold of the SDK.
So, you can go to developer dot Android dot
com and start looking through on how to write
Android applications.
That's gonna be the best thing to do.
We have a great design site at developer dot
Android dot com forward slash design.
And in there, there's some pages around pure
Android, which actually hints as to how things
should look across different platforms.
So, it'll help with redesigning the application
so it looks and fits better into the Android
ecosystem.
Makes use of the back button.
>>Nick: It's the only thing about this topic
is I think the industry as a whole is gonna
struggle with this a bit.
And a lot of people have looked toward HTML
5 and other hybrid technologies to be the
shining light that rides in from the East,
saves you so you only have to write your app
once and it runs perfectly on every single
different platform out there.
But I think that's never really come to pass.
I think if you take a look at Facebook, for
example, used to be the poster child for this
movement where they were writing a lot in
HTML.
And while it may have simplified the development
process, I think most people agree that it
didn't yield the best possible user experience
in their applications.
And it's interesting to see those guys.
You see Facebook turning around and saying
now that they're gonna focus on native mobile
applications.
So, I think that really speaks to the fact
that if you wanna have a best in class, really
responsive, useful application, then you really
need to go native.
That's my view.
>>Richard: Yeah.
I kind of agree.
I mean, there are solutions which do cross-platform
output from HTML to Titaniums and phone gaps
of the world, but I'm still yet to see an
application that was done one of those cross-platform
solutions that you couldn't tell wasn't native--the
bounce backs done in Java Script, the list-scrollings,
things like that.
The native components, the UI components,
across various versions of Android, it all
is pretty clear, upfront that the application
you're using is a web-based application or
HTML cross-platform application.
>>Nick: Yeah, you get things like links in
apps which just look massively out of place--highlights
kind of wrong and scrolling is slightly off
and it just feels wrong.
>>Richard: And, of course, you can't take
advantage of a lot of the platform features
that Android has for supporting multiple devices--supporting
the seven-inch devices.
Nexus 7.
>>Al: It's quite interesting.
I see that Facebook at the moment I know are
hiring Android engineers.
So, they definitely are moving away from the
HTML 5 experience.
>>Nick and Richard: Who are? Facebook?
>>Nick: Jobs for Android engineers.
And they obviously bought Lightbulb.
A talent acquisition?
I don't know.
>>Al: I've heard it's a talent acquisition
rather than anything else.
So, yeah.
They're definitely taking people on, so hopefully
we'll see something good from them in the
future.
>>Richard: Yeah, it should be.
There's been lots of reports of the number
of users of Facebook that are only doing it
from mobile now.
Hundreds of millions or whatever, that it's
just from mobile.
>>Nick: That's [inaudible].
>>Richard: OK.
Where are all the viewers today?
Well, we have viewers on YouTube.
We need some people to join in the Hangout.
Come along and ask some questions like we
have.
>>Nick: Has the men's time trial started?
We're almost up against the men's time trial.
How can we compete against them?
>>Richard: We get a second live stream in?
And then people can come to the Hangout to
watch it?
>>Nick: Yeah.
Why not?
>>Al: We need the Android power exercise bike
from IO 11 in.
>>Richard: Cheers to you.
>>Nick: Good memory.
>>Richard: The ADK Android exercise bikes.
>>Nick: Brilliant.
>>Richard: OK.
Let's have a look at the next question up
there.
>>Nick: As they try to--.
>>Richard: The Google Play content policies
have changed.
They have, indeed.
If you're an Android developer, you would've
got an email today saying that we've updated
our policies for distributing applications
in Google Play.
There's details for that inside the email
and then you can look through the link for
the Google policy.
>>Nick: [unintelligible]
>>Richard: Yeah, you should have little bar
at the top."So, the policy about games incentivizing
ratings on the market was there already,"
says Mathis, "but it was never really enforced.
Will it be enforced from now on?"
So, it's a tricky one.
I mean, we don't look at every single game
and play every single application in the Play
Store, we don't have people that do that.
That's not how the Play Store works.
We're a much more open ecosystem.
However, we have systems that look through
the Google Play portfolio of applications.
It's one of the reasons why it takes a little
bit longer for your applications to get published
now.
We have systems that are bouncer, indeed,
that's looking for malware, specifically.
But we also do look out for things like applications
which have a suspicious number of five-star
ratings over a short period of time.
So there are systems looking out for these
things.
And of course, we can use those to try and
highlight the apps.
But the main point here is you're definitely
not gonna get your application featured if
you have this kind of functionality in the
application.
So, the apps that do get fully tested are
the ones that go through featuring, editor's
choice, and staff picks.
>>Nick: There's also some subtleties in what
we consider incentivizing as well.
Like, you can say, "Please rate my app."
And the best way to do that is to have a yes/no/never
kind of thing, so you don't annoy the user
pumping it all the time.
But you can't say, "Please rate my app five-stars."
'Cause that's trying to influence the way
to do it.
And you certainly can't say, "Rate my app
five-stars to get X." 'Cause, well, it's just
a lie.
There's no way for the app to actually determine
what your rating was.
So there's subtleties in what you can and
can't do.
So, maybe Mathis isn't clear about that.
You can actually ask people to say, "Please
rate my app if you find it useful."
And please do that in the non-annoying way.
But yeah.
You can't really incentivize them to rate
it, to a particular rating, which I would
imagine to be five stars.
>>Al: There is, of course, the ability to
report apps in the Play Store.
>>Richard: There is at the bottom of every
app listed on a mobile device.
You can scroll down and report apps.
And there's an inappropriate apps form for
reporting on the web store as well.
Yeah, you really don't want to start getting
your applications banned.
Three of those and you can get your account
shut down and other things.
So, it's just much better to abide by the
content policies, how they're laid out.
And not try and work around them in any way.
Now, they have been made more specific in
a few of these areas now.
>>Nick: I think the changes are better.
I think they clarify that stuff and I think
they add a few more examples about things
which I've seen people confused about in the
past.
>>Al: One of the big changes, it seems, to
be getting rid of something that bugged me,
which was notification adverts.
You'd get adverts that appear as system notifications.
They would just, I've not met anyone who have
found those useful or actually used them to
click on without thinking that they were something
useful in terms of a notification from an
app rather than an advert.
>>Richard: Yeah.
I'll talk about advertising.
We might as well go into that a little bit.
We've made it very specific now that adverts
inside your application must also abide by
the same rules as your entire application.
You're fully responsible for every advert
that's shown in that app.
So, if, for example, you're using an advertising
platform and the end user is turning gambling
adverts off, you should turn them off instantly
because if gambling adverts start appearing
inside your application and they link through
to live gambling sites, your application can
get banned from the store for that.
You can get taken down.
People can report it when they can find it.
So just be aware that you are fully responsible
for every advert that shows in the app.
Don't put them in the wrong places.
Don't mislead users into clicking them.
>>Nick: Don't show adult ads in an app that
is rated E for everyone.
>>Richard: Yeah, also true.
Yup.
So, just be a bit more careful on the ads
as well.
And this was all covered in the guidelines
before.
Now, it's just very specific and a little
bit clearer.
OK.
So, if anyone has any other questions about
the new guidelines, we'll ping them through.
Where are we?
Huh.
>>Nick: One, one.
>>Richard: OK.
Why not?
From V-1-P. Do you want to go for that one?
>>Nick: V-1-P asks, "How can I access the
phone's incoming call screen inside of my
application?"
You can't.
>>Richard: No.
There's a couple of things that you can't
do and that's one of them.
You can't muck about with people's phone calls.
>>Al: Unless you wrote your own firmware.
Get a hold of the AOSP.
>>Richard: You can do it on your own device
if you really wanted to.
>>Nick: There's actually some apps which try
and do things a bit clever, don't they?
Like, by having a window floating on top of
it.
There was the app [unintelligible], I remember
a while ago, which tried to give you extra
options when you were in call to someone,
so you could easily share your location with
them or send them an image, like while you're
on the call.
They try and do strange floaty over the incoming
call screen thing, but you can't actually
have interaction with that.
>>Al: There's nothing stopping you though
writing your own dialer application, to dial
out.
It's just the incoming calls you can't intercept.
Is that right?
>>Richard: Yes.
Skype in an example of that.
When you want to make a call, if you've got
Skype installed, it'll come up and say, "Do
you want to make this phone call using dial-up
or Skype?"
You can register for that intent and them
as well.
We saw our first application today come through
that was also now registering for this action.
So, when you do that, an ad comes up and says,
"Do you want to use Google now or do you want
to use--?"
>>Nick: Swiping up from the bottom.
>>Richard: Yeah, the swiping up from the bottom.
Actually, it normally launches Google Now
on these devices.
>>Nick: It's changing it.
>>Richard: It's changing it.
Do you know what the intent was?
>>Nick: Actually, I heard it was intent dot
inassist?
>>Richard: Could be.
It's there, documented in the latest developer
docs.
I think it was.
>>Nick: In the source code of [unintelligible].
[laughter]
>>Richard: Just run off the Java and you'll
be fine.
>>Nick: Hi, David.
>>Richard: Yeah, hi David.
>>David: Hi everybody.
>>Richard: So you can't, exit on the screen
there.
>>Nick: OK.
>>Richard: Let's just go back to the thread
and see if anyone else has made a comment.
Are you in the comments here?
Oh.
OK.
[unintelligible].
Alex, who's also lost inside.
I'll ask on the moderator.
[pause]
FreeSoul, who is probably the same person
as Alex, asks, "Can I make clickable drawables
inside a text view?
The drawable created using HTML Image Getter
from Image is downloaded from the web.
I want to be able to zoom the images."
Can I make clickable drawables from inside
of text view?
No.
>>Nick: So, I'm guessing he's using HTML from
HTML or link to some linkable methods to try
and turn some HTML, set some HTML in text
view, right?
>>Richard: Mm-hmm.
>>Nick: Will that load images?
>>Richard: I don't think so.
>>Nick: Oh, David has joined the Hangout.
Do you want to explain your issue?
>>Richard: That's not his question.
>>Nick: Oh, it's not?
>>Richard: No.
>>Nick: Oh, sorry.
>>Richard: That's all right.
>>David: I do have a question.
>>Richard: OK.
Well, we'll think about Alex's question whilst
you ask yours, if you want.
>>Nick: Oh, sorry.
>>David: Yeah.
So, you know how they have all these phone
gaps and other APIs and tools to help you
do cross platform?
Is there any framework, just the idea of a
framework of a lightweight like, wrapper,
like maybe Google Docs does, where that it's
more of like a link?
Like, the app icon launcher would be almost
like a link and have a lightweight amount
of meta data about the person.
But if you're always connected to the web,
it would go to the website and download like,
HTML 5 pages on there.
So, maybe keeps your login credentials and
some meta data about you, but really it's,
uses the HTML--.
>>Richard: We understand.
I guess in some respects the browser does
all that for you anyway.
It says you can save login details.
You can do that kind of identification using
Chrome or the normal browser on Android.
So, you could just get away with making a
bookmark and then saving that bookmark to
your home screen.
If you wanted to go and write a custom launcher--.
>>David: I'm thinking like a framework that
other people can adopt so that it kind of,
the user doesn't know.
It looks native.
They think it's native, but I don't know if
there's something out there.
I wouldn't want to go out and create this
if it already existed.
I looked around, but I was just wondering
if you guys knew.
>>Richard: I don't know of a specific framework,
but in terms of lines of code, it would be,
it wouldn't be particularly many.
>>David: Yeah.
>>Richard: You can add view and load things
into it.
>>Nick: Why do you want to fool people into
thinking they're in a native app.
>>David: Well, not fool, but more of, you
have HTML 5 people and everyone wants their
own little app.
Everyone wants that little icon on there.
They don't want people to think, "Oh, I'm
going to the web."
Also, a lot of people want to natively control,
like, here's your login screen, here's some
credentials.
And it's more of a perception.
Yeah, it's not fool, but it's more of a user
perception, "Hey, I've launched that icon.
Hey, I got this app."
But if most of your stuff is making JSON calls
or calls to the web, why not use a common
language that everyone knows?
>>Richard: PhoneGap does actually let you
do that.
It does let you have the pages which load
the data straight from the web.
>>David: OK.
>>Al: So I guess it's probably worth bringing
up web view, which is an object you can use
in Android where you create a native app and
it uses a web view.
And a web view is populated from an HTML source.
So, you can use that and connect back to your
main application.
And you can use a Java Script interface if
you want to call into native code.
So, you can make some small tweaks to make
it a little bit more native and make some
use of Android's functionality without going
fully down the route of having a complete
Android application.
But once again, as the guy said earlier, it's
usually better to go down the route of an
Android app if you've got the resources to
do it.
Its users tend to spot HTML 5 apps, whatever
you do.
>>David: Yeah, and I was just, I was just
putting that idea out there to see if someone's
done it 'cause, and to get your input from
it 'cause I was just thinking about doing
it instead of going totally native.
So, I mean, I've always been, I've done native
and done the JSON, but I was saying well,
if it's out there or if you thought maybe
it was a good idea or something like that,
'cause I--.
>>Nick: I would say be cautious of doing that
'cause like you say, everyone wants an app
experience, have an icon on the home screen
and whatnot.
But just being really cognizant of when they
launch that, they're expecting an app experience.
And if what they are getting is a web experience,
which is slightly different and you get into
this uncanny valley where the interactions
aren't quite the same.
With an app you set an expectation.
It's gonna work one way.
It's gonna be really responsive.
It's gonna-- buttons are gonna do one thing,
rather than have links or something like that.
So, just be real careful about mixing those
two metaphors.
>>David: Yeah, I know.
Great.
Thank you.
I just, something that was always on my mind
and I was wondering--.
I have another question too, but you can go
to the other guys first and I'll wait.
>>Richard: No, it's OK.
Go ahead with your question, yeah.
It's fine.
>>David: I have a little app called Magnifying
Glass.
And so, this app uses a camera on many different
phones.
And even though I say, "OK, use the permissions
and make sure they have zoom and everything
else," I found out I'd given a way to someone
can zoom and send me the parameters of their
camera.
And I see oh, it doesn't have a zoom or it
doesn't have, it doesn't support it, but it
still is able, they were able to download
it.
And it's usually the cheaper phones that it
doesn't work real well.
But I really get a lot of people-- bad comments,
like hey, you, some really good ones that
are pretty-- it's free, too.
But I don't wanna repeat the words.
And I was wondering, I'm just, I'm not a big
company and everything, and I heard about
being able to moderate or respond to people,
because I'll use a generic term like "stinks--"
one word, stinks.
And one star.
I'd like to be able to ask a question, like
"Why does it stink?"
And everything else.
And that's probably the new one.
If you look at it, that's, I rewrote it for
Ice Cream Sandwich.
So, there's older versions.
Yeah, and it also has a mirror now, too.
Yeah, that's me.
[laughs] And you can do a mirror, too.
So, I did it for my girlfriend so she can
do her lipstick now, too.
So, abuse the men.
And, but you'll see on there that some of
the focusing and other things like that doesn't,
I have it so you have to click on the focus
something because Motorola is notoriously
bad at accepting the basic APIs.
Like, even the zoom.
Like I say, even doing the regular zoom.
So, I--.
>>Richard: What do you mean by that?
>>David: Well, what I, the actual properties.
You know when you have the properties, you
give the set zoom and you give it the zoom
value?
I've gotten back people saying, "Hey, it doesn't
work."
And then I have a friend that has a Motorola
phone.
I can't remember the version of it.
And he's like, "Oh, yeah.
You only have to do a work around with the
camera, though."
>>Richard: So, those camera settings should
be added to the compatibility test suite,
if they're not already in there.
>>David: Yeah.
>>Richard: It shouldn't be getting through
with those kinds of bugs in them.
>>David: Yeah.
And I, sometimes I think it maybe it's people
just don't know how to use it.
I thought it was pretty intuitive to use.
But I mean, I would like that.
Is there any way, how do I go about?
I send in request after request through the
whole developer store 'cause I'm the top-level
person.
I'm the only one on my developer store.
So, I wanted to do that.
>>Nick: To who, sorry?
>>David: Through, to Google.
To the ether.
I went through the developer store, the help,
and what form, tried to fill out forms.
Is this about--?
There's nothing about development or a question
like that to ask for that directly.
It's more like, "Oh, for billing."
So, I did it for general.
>>Richard: If you have some development questions,
we would definitely recommend going onto Stack
Overflow or the Android Google group.
The Stack Overflow--.
>>David: But this wouldn't be developer.
This is definitely just for the store, no
development question.
This is just how can I have that top level
request to talk to the people who say--?
>>Richard: I see, yeah.
To respond to comments.
So, yeah.
>>Nick: There's no form to request that.
Yeah.
It's only the people who have the top developer
badge right now.
>>David: OK.
So, I'm, but I'm the main owner of mine.
So, how do I, can I ever get onto that?
>>Nick: Top developer is a badge awarded to
certain developers, not top as in groups.
>>David: Ah.
OK.
>>Al: Only one other thing that might be useful
is mentioning what the remote testing service
is like, or is it Perfecto Mobile, where if
someone reports a boot problem from a specific
device, you can get some time on a device
that they host.
And you just get an end face to it.
And you can see whether you can reproduce
the problem and then you can get a bit of
a head start in debugging on that specific
device.
>>Richard: Yeah.
Specifically to say, I mean, the top developer
badge, which does at the moment get good response
and comments.
Since we announced it at Google IO, we've
had a lot of requests to be top developer
come through.
A whole lot of requests for people asking
to get the "respond to comments" functionality.
And right now, it's limited to that group
and we don't have any more announcements on
before when that would be expanded.
>>Nick: It's just that, when we're developing
a feature, we only want a small set of users
about it and give us feedback on it.
So, you know?
>>David: Well, and then my next question is,
why can't anyone help me?
I Open Sourced this a long time ago.
It's on Google, I have a link to it.
It's hosted by Google.
And I have even both branches on Google Ice
Cream and checked it in.
And I don't put the code out there in the
wild.
You have to like, ask to join.
And I only had one person ever ask to join,
but he never followed through.
But it's free, you know?
I was like, "I'll give you credit.
I'll put it out--."
All that stuff.
And I just, I was, it's remarkable.
Sometimes, you get people to help.
I only have a few people that downloaded it.
>>Richard: Yeah.
I have apps with similar numbers of downloads
that are Open Sourced as well.
And it's very rare that you get anyone else
just going through and deciding to commit
to the application.
You need to go to user groups in your area--Android
user groups or Google developer user groups.
And then get some interest in it.
And then some people who you actually meet
face to face maybe commit to doing something.
>>David: Yeah.
'Cause it only has like, 240 thousand or something
like that, plus I got kicked off the group
once.
I still have 30 thousand from the other IP.
Google slapped my hand one time.
[laughter]
>>Richard: You don't have to go into that.
>>David: Sorry about that.
I didn't mean to do it, but that was--.
>>Nick: Yeah.
To get back to the camera issue, I think you
get into the important thing is that it sounds
like there's bugs in the OEM implementation
in the camera.
Like, they'll see you're not using our camera,
but using their camera and they're basically
not really called API.
So, the thing you can do pragmatically is
black list the device until you manage to
get some decent debugging work around it and
all that.
But the best answer is to submit a CCS test,
so this is a suite of tests which every phone
has to pass in order to get in the Play Store
and Gmail and Google Maps and stuff like that.
So, if you go to source dot Android dot com,
and it has instructions there about how to
write and submit a CCS test.
And that would be doing everyone in the world
a favor.
>>David: Oh, awesome.
Yeah, I'll start doing that.
I have the old one.
I did it, it seems like the newer phones with
Jellybean, 'cause I have Jellybean and Ice
Cream Sandwich, that they're not sending them
to me.
And plus, I did the new UI and some people
get mad at the little icon bar, but they're
getting used to it.
But the old one, yeah, the old app, I actually
had a way that you could contact me.
I don't do--[audio cuts out for a few seconds]--
internet connection or anything else like
that.
People like that, too, because there's no
advertisements.
>>Nick: No permissions is good.
>>David: All right.
Thank you.
>>Richard: All right.
Thanks for coming in today, then.
It was nice talking to you.
Feel free to stay in if you want to hang out.
>>David: Yeah.
I like doing this.
>>Richard: What comment is that?
Anything interesting coming in on that comment
string?
What language is it?
Is it in Android?
OK.
Let's go back to the moderator and.
[pause]
Someone is asking, "How can I set the shooting
mode for the camera of your application?"
Interesting.
Well, maybe David can even answer that.
He seems to be--.
He uses the camera quite a lot.
Have you ever looked into the different shooting
modes for the camera, David?
>>David: Yeah.
If you go to the properties, I think it's
shooting dash modes.
So, you have to go get camera dot-- to get
the properties.
I forgot the actual method call.
And then there it comes back name value pairs.
And it'll tell you the different modes that
they have.
And then from there, you have to read and--.
And so, there's, like in Motorola, there was
actually moto dash zoom.
And there's a moto dash shoot.
It's really neat to look at some of the added
properties.
A lot of cameras have--.
>>Richard: Where are you finding those?
In the properties, where did you find the
Motorola specific programs?
>>David: I print them all out.
You can do to flatten on the properties and
that's all I do.
So, once you get the properties, say, dot
flatten--.
And it just prints out all of them.
And I just take all that and I call the email
client and send those to it as a body of message
and put my email in there.
And so, it's up to the user to send me it,
but oh, I'll tell you.
I get a lot.
>>Richard: Tell me.
You get users sending those in?
>>David: I get at least six a day.
Some of them just send me the properties with
no input.
So, I tried to like, get this whole support
going on my own.
I mean, I'm doing this for free.
This is my hobby.
>>Richard: So, you probably have one of the
most comprehensive libraries on camera settings
ever.
>>David: Yeah, I do.
[laughs] I could probably, and I'm willing
to give it to you 'cause I don't, I don't,
it doesn't give you any specific user information.
It's just the properties.
>>Richard: Well, man.
We'll talk to you about that afterwards.
It would be interesting if you could post
it somewhere where we could repost it on our
Google+ page.
>>David: Yeah.
They're all emails.
They're all emails and I even, I have them
in Gmail bulk.
>>Richard: Just waiting for the bug reports
to come in.
Excellent.
That was quite a comprehensive answer.
So the camera question from Andre.
[pause]
Have we got anything else?
>>Al: We got some new moderator stuff that
seems to be popping up.
[pause]
There's an interesting one there.
I need to use some hard coded credentials
in my app.
For example, the mail address that is used
to send a bug report or the couple ID key
used for O-auth.
Is there a way to protect this data?
[laughter]
>>Richard: No.
Umm.
Yeah.
We would suggest that, especially for O-auth
key, the thing about it potentially not keeping
it inside the application.
You keep them on the website for support if
you need them.
There was a good talk from last year's IO
in 2011.
The pirates and vampires talk by Dan Galpin.
You'll actually run into how to secure data
because there are things inside LVL, license
verification, that are very useful to secure.
And then run into, of course, obfuscating
your code.
It run into if you really wanted to make it
more secure using the NDK.
And then put the secure information in the
native layer and pull through to it, so it's
much harder to decompile it and get hold of
it.
Al has just linked to the "pirates and vampires"
talk.
There's some information on Stack Overflow,
if you search for the same kind of things
that have secure keys inside Android.
But as far as the standardized, I think what
you're looking for is a standard, secure,
to put it in its place.
There isn't actually an answer for that that
I know about.
It's up to you to sift through that data.
And one of the more secure ways to do that
is to go through [audio noise obscures speech].
--just joined the Hangout.
Hey.
Stephan.
>>Stephan: I have a short question.
Currently, I am doing to get our application
hardware attribute accelerated.
And we found several methods which are not
supported but use acceleration, especially
the draw path, the draw from text, is one
of them.
And we're using them.
Do you know any substitutions for this?
>>Richard: So we do have a list of the methods
that aren't supported.
Certainly, we had it for Ice Cream Sandwich.
I haven't actually seen an updated list for
Jellybean.
Have you seen one for that?
OK.
It probably hasn't changed.
So, no I don't know of an alternative for
using draw path accelerated.
Of course, you can turn acceleration on and
off around the screen at the time that you're
using.
The, one of the sources of our information
is checking the manuals from top Google IO
2011 as well.
They have it.
>>Nick: Yes.
The only thing you can do is [unintelligible].
>>Stephan: I really didn't understand you.
>>Nick: The path from which you're rendering
your text [unintelligible].
And then
you can just re-render that same.
>>Stephan: The text is not changing, but the
background is changing.
[pause]
OK.
I will try this.
>>Nick: [unintelligible].
>>Stephan: OK.
I have seen this from [unintelligible].
>>Richard: As far as I know nothing has changed.
And even if it had changed for Jellybean,
you'd obviously need to still support the
previous versions anyway.
>>Stephan: Yeah.
>>Richard: And most changes to hybrid acceleration
in Jellybean would have done around the web
view.
The new web viewing inside Jellybean is--
a lot more of the elements in there are hybrid
[unintelligible].
>>Stephan: OK.
Cool.
>>Richard: I assume it's a similar story.
>>Stephan: Yeah, thanks.
>>Richard: No problem.
Hi, Islam.
I can see you here as well.
I had you [unintelligible].
Oh well.
I'll just type it in instead.
Here.
OK.
Where are we?
2:37.
Back to the moderator.
What's the best channel for suggesting ideas
for Android?
>>David: This one.
I just asked and suggested that framework.
>>Richard: Yes, come and ask.
You get to talk directly to Google.
But source dot Android dot com is the place
to go.
>>Al: If it's a big change, there's an Android
contributing Google group, which people can
save big chunks of code that they want to
submit.
And then they can code it up, submit it to
the Android Open Source Project and eventually,
it'll filter it's way through.
>>Richard: Yep.
You can go into the Android discuss forum
on Google groups and start suggesting it in
there as well.
All these places are monitored by Googlers.
And you can have a look for ideas.
But probably discussions--.
OK.
[unintelligible].
But the places to go suggest it that the Googlers
are looking--.
>>Nick: [unintelligible] you can choose [unintelligible]
the feature request [unintelligible].
>>Richard: Must have put [unintelligible]
in.
And the source as well.
>>David: Can you put the link for the source
thing?
>>Richard: Yeah, sure.
>>David: Thanks, sorry.
>>Richard: Just source Android dot--
>>David: I always look in, the one to submit
to the Open Source Project.
>>Nick: The instructions are on that page.
>>David: Oh, OK.
There it is.
OK.
>>Al: I put the link to the group up as well.
>>Nick: Al, do you want to talk real quickly,
for you had some submissions accepted into
AOSP, right?
>>Al: Sure, yeah.
Basically, if you've got a large chunk of
functionality, the best place to go to start
off is Android [unintelligible] group.
And that's the place where your idea gets
bounced around.
People then tweak it to what would fit into
the Android way, what would be better suited
to the current code base.
Once you've done that, you can submit your
code to the Android Open Source Project.
A lot of the stuff for that, you get from
Open Source dot Android dot com.
You submit your patches into what's known
as Garrett.
And that's a system where those patches can
then be reviewed by Googlers, they can be
approved, they can be commented on.
Sometimes, things that may make sense, given
the current code base, may get held back because
there are changes in the internal Google repository
that aren't public yet, may knock on what
you're trying to do.
So, once you're in Garrett, you may see things
that don't make sense at that time, but in
the future, may make a little more sense.
Once those are accepted, they end up into
the Android Open Source Project code base.
When you're playing around with that, the
best branch of code to play with is called
the master branch because that's where all
the development goes on.
Once those are in there, then there a quite
good chance that they will eventually make
their way into the next major release of Android.
>>Nick: It's also worth noting the best time
to make a contribution is just after we've
Open Sourced a release 'cause that's the point
at which the other AOSP is, I guess, the closest
to master.
So, it has the least likelihood to collide
with an internal change.
That's it.
>>Al: Absolutely.
But it's definitely worth re-emphasizing that
submitting changes to an existing release
as an external contributor, it's very unlikely
that things will be accepted unless they're
going into the compatibility test suite, CTS,
because a lot of the development for releases
which are made, like Jellybean, has already
been frozen.
So, there's not gonna be big features added
to it or anything else like that.
It's always worth adding new stuff in master
rather than picking a specific release.
>>Richard: Right.
Thank you, Al.
>>Nick: Any more questions you'd like to ask?
So, Sam from Florida asks on moderator, "What's
the best advised way to sync timing in an
app?
For example, switching rotation while a timer
is running.
Is a service the best way to do it?"
>>Richard: A service is definitely, yeah,
a reasonable--.
>>Nick: We offer an ultimate stopwatch.
The ultimate stopwatch app on the Play Store.
>>Richard: Yep.
>>Nick: You can ask Rich this question.
>>Richard: So, [unintelligible].
>>Nick: [unintelligible], too.
>>Richard: I say it's the share practices
in on call technology.
Isn't it slightly--?
Oh no.
I do.
I was gonna be embarrassed to not having my
own application installed, but I do have it
installed.
The nice thing about using on pause and on
resume, is that the app is going.
You can hit, 21 seconds, you can hit the home
button.
And it looks like it's gone into the background,
but it's still running.
And when you go back to it, it'll have carried
on from, it looks like it's carrying on from
the background.
So, it's 33 seconds.
But that's all just made through unpause.
I just store the current time on the clock
as well as the current real time.
And then resume, I just set it back to where
it would be.
>>Nick: You don't have to commit to adding
the new Jellybean notification chronometer
API.
You can carry on counting in my status in
my notification bar.
>>Richard: So then this goes into the background
and I have counting going on in the notification
bar.
And exactly to this point, we go into, when
we rotate, I do the on pause, on resume as
well.
>>Nick: So you're using shared references?
I know that idea has, according to the moderator,
is using the bundle, which is passing on destroy.
You can save it in that bundle.
>>Al: There's also, if it's not necessarily
showing the time using the alarm manager to
set future events, if they're just looking
for a way of saying, "In 15 minutes, I want
something to fire off."
>>Richard: That's a fantastic point, Al, because
Ultimate Stopwatch also has a countdown timer
mode.
And when you switch modes to the countdown
timer and you put your time of one minute
in, again, it's counting down.
And when you do that, it actually shuts the
app down.
And this time, it's used the alarm manager
to set an alarm in 58 second's time.
So, the countdown still, still beats.
And it looks like it's counting down in the
background, but actually, the app's shut down
and it's just using the alarm manager.
I'll wait for that to go off in a minute to
check if it's still working.
Haven't tested it in ages.
[laughs] But yeah, the chronometer using the
application's things is a good idea.
>>Nick: And countdown timer is good for doing
punch dates.
>>Richard: That was useful.
Well, the new thing in London now tends to
want everyone to shower within four minutes.
So, you could put your phone inside a freezer
bag and use it there, counting down your four-minute
shower and saving water.
Then maybe, we can use the icebox again.
>>Nick: This week on [ ] Apps.
>>Richard: My other app is also--.
Would you like to look at the source code?
The Ultimate Stopwatch is also Open Source
on Google Code.
So, you can just look through the code for
that and see how it's done.
>>Nick: So, Dave, service, it sounds like
a bit of a heavyweight approach.
>>David: I have another--.
So, you know how now most apps, you have the,
when you're paying for one or even a free
one, EULA, the end user agreement?
Is there anything you know, I haven't looked
in the Open Source Project.
Is there anything like the framework is gonna
just come up with that so there's a consistent
one look where you just put in your user agreement?
Isn't it, I mean, isn't that kind of canned?
You put in--.
>>Nick: Are you talking about where you, which
EULA are you talking about?
>>David: The end user agreement.
So, more like, I accept or don't accept, some
kind of standard thing that you could call
to, like an API instead of--.
>>Nick: One in the app?
You mean, one that keeps showing when you
launch an app, for example?
>>David: Yeah.
And so they would be something that's given
to you by the Play Store, so you could, it
takes you to the Play Store.
And the Play Store says yeah and saves that,
just like with your in-app purchases to this
and that.
So, it's something that it would manage instead
of you having to manage that in your--.
You're already doing it for the--.
>>Nick: Wasn't that, that's an interesting
area 'cause we're actually handling the app
purchase.
So, we know what's going on there and we can
be confident that a EULA covers that.
If it's some behavior which your app then
goes on to do, like, I don't know if we can
suggest some legal text.
That sounds murky to me.
I do know there's some templates out there
for store developers, like that don't have
the resources to engage a lawyer to write
these things for them.
But I know there's some like, creative commons
licenses out there where you basically go
through and fill in a wizard to send your
app name and what you wanna do.
It'll give you some standard ones, like location
based app and whatever app.
I'm gonna try--.
>>David: I'm not talking about the text.
I'm talking about just the part of the API
where that all Play Store.
And you pass in that verbiage.
So, I'm not, we don't want you to be a lawyer.
>>Richard: So, we do have it for privacy policies
already.
But, of course, privacy policies don't need
to be accepted by the user explicitly in the
same way that end user license agreements
usually do.
So, you're right.
It's still up to the application to provide
a dialogue or some kind of acceptance so they
can see end user agreement and accept it explicitly
there and have it have the time stamp or whatever.
>>Al: Most of the ones I've seen tend to just
be a scrolling text view with an OK or cancel
button at the bottom.
>>David: That's what I have on my one app,
but I'm just, you know?
It would be nice to be able to say, "A third
party."
Also, a third party has captured your agreement,
too.
It's not something in my app that I could
have manipulated.
When you get lawyers involved--.
>>Nick: We do already release the permissions
for apps, so when you hit in store, it pops
up saying that these are the permissions they
use and you have to accept and store.
You talking about that level?
>>David: Yeah, something like that.
Here's the end user agreement, too.
Boom.
So, it's something I fill out in the Play
Store, not in the app itself.
And then I can say to the lawyer when someone's--,
"Look, I didn't manipulate this in my code.
Here's the time stamp.
It's a true time stamp because look, it's
managed by the Play Store."
>>Richard: Interesting.
I guess it's quite a lot of infrastructure
on and support from outside if we did build
it.
We need to give you access to the list of
users that have accepted it, which versions
of your unit they've accepted, when they accepted
it and all that kind of thing.
>>David: Or I wouldn't even need that.
I'm only thinking like, if I get sued or something.
Yeah, I would say go to Google and make a
request for it.
Maybe something like that, like where you
can make a request 'cause it's not gonna be
like something I need like that.
I just need a, this is gonna be, if it's a
long battle, you just say, "Hey, here," and
make a formal request and get it.
>>Richard: Interesting.
>>David: And I don't know why I would need
it unless, you know?
>>Richard: Something goes wrong.
Well, we sit next to the, the play publisher
site team.
We'll mention it to them and see what they
say.
You never know.
>>David: They'll probably shoot me.
[laughs]
>>Richard: Who knows whether they've had that
suggested before or not?
They got a lot of feedback, this kind of feedback,
quite recently when they were working with
Google IO, which they are looking through.
But I'll definitely add it to the list of
feedback and see what they say.
Who knows?
Do we have any more moderator questions?
Best chance testing ideas--.
I have a library project, OK.
This is, looks like a new one.
I have a library project, this is from Dave,
with a content provider and multiple application
projects that reference the library.
I can't install both client applications at
the same time because of the content provider.
Any suggestions on how to solve?
>>Al: You need to use a different name space
for the content provider in each app.
>>Richard: Yeah.
The content provider, you can't have the same
content provider twice on the device.
It wouldn't make any sense.
So, the content provider, I mean, it's like
saying that your two apps have the same package
name.
It's just not gonna work.
I mean, you have to create two apps building
on the library with different package names
and give the name space of the content provider.
Actually, the name space of the content provider
should often include the package name anyway
into the same name space.
So, they should be different.
[pause]
>>Al: It would be pretty confusing to a user
to have two content providers providing different
data in the same name space.
I mean, it's, I can't see of a use where you'd
want to do it.
>>Richard: And how would you know which one
you were talking to and yeah?
>>Al: Yeah.
[pause]
>>Richard: OK.
>>Al: There's another new one in there at
the moment.
I use a fragment class in five tabs.
I want to know what the tab is being created
in the background, what the tab is being created
in the background.
I realize DVM created two tabs even though
it has five, eg, I click on tab three, the
tab one will be destroyed and tab four will
be created in the background.
>>Nick: What's DVM?
>>Al: I'm guessing it's a Dalvik Virtual Machine.
>>Nick: OK.
Yeah.
You're right.
>>Al: I hope you guys understood the question
'cause I'm not too sure what's being asked.
>>Nick: He's basically asking, look, 'cause
he's essentially using adapter, right?
So it adapts all to supply views.
Or only can substantiate them when they're
needed so that you can handle arbitrarily
large data sets.
So I think that's your major problem.
He wants to know why all five aren't created,
it sounds like.
>>David: I think you want to know when the
tab is being created.
Or, which one is being created next.
[pause]
>>Richard: Yeah.
I mean, he's the one who's providing the layouts.
I don't really understand.
OK.
If you're using the view pager.
>>Nick: Oh, he's on view pager.
>>Richard: If you're using view pager, then,
of course, you've got to provide the pages
and it will say, once you get to page three,
page one gets cleared out and page four will
be requested.
So, you will keep swiping through them all.
>>Nick: And you can set how many tabs in advance.
>>Richard: The question is, is he using a
view pager or has he just got five tabs and
each one has, each one has a fragment in it?
If that's the case, then there isn't any preloading
that I'm aware of.
So, one would be shuffling tab one out of
memory and loading tab four when you click
on tab three.
Unless you do have some kind of adapter in
place in the view pager and these kind of
things.
>>Nick: Yeah, I think it really depends on
your view pager.
There's just a new layout, so [unintelligible].
>>Richard: Yeah.
And also, they're your fragments, so you'll
know when their life cycle is changing.
And that's exactly when--.
>>Nick: We'll need more details than that.
Perhaps, if you could post a bit more information.
Yeah, I must say, if you post some more information
and maybe some code samples to Stack Overflow
and link to it in the moderator, that might
help us.
Maybe a bit more information to go on there.
>>Richard: Yeah.
There's a few different scenarios around that.
OK, anything else in the comments before we
bring other questions from inside the Hangout?
If not, I'll have a look for comments and
maybe we'll close up early.
>>Al: We'll have time to see Bradley Wiggins
in the Olympics.
>>Richard: Right.
Not that we're legging it off to go watch
the Olympics.
>>Nick: This room says up in seven minutes.
Sorry, what?
You said that?
>>Richard: It's all right.
[laughs]
>>David: What about Phelps?
Is that a big thing?
Yeah?
>>Nick: Yeah, no.
Good for him.
>>David: Do you think it's gonna be broken?
>>Nick: Who knows, eh?
Swimmers seem to be able to compete in a lot
of events.
I can't see--.
[laughter]
>>David: Nice.
>>Richard: I'm watching the Olympics on my
Nexus 7.
>>David: I didn't get to go to Google IO.
>>Nick: Yeah, I'm really impressed with Phelps.
It must be another swimmer who, if anyone,
is gonna beat that, right?
'Cause no one else seems to do as many events.
Like, is it his third Games or second?
>>Al: The rowers seem to be in for quite a
lot.
>>Nick: Yeah?
>>Al: But yeah.
But they, what's it say, is it 19 medals he's
at now?
It's incredible.
>>Nick: Who's got the previous record?
>>David: The Russian girl.
I'm trying to remember her name, was like
34 years ago or something like that.
>>Nick: What did she do?
>>David: She was gymnastics.
>>Nick: Huh.
>>David: Which is a lot of different events.
You have team events and your separate personal
events.
>>Nick: Nice.
Well, I'm cheering for Bradley.
What's it, this will be his, he'll be our
most medalled, best ever for Britain if he
wins today's game.
>>Richard: We are very much enjoying the Olympics.
Haven't gone the whole time.
One final question from Catherine just came
in saying, "Can you provide an example of
a very simple privacy policy?"
I don't have one.
I imagine if you looked on the internets for
one, one would come up pretty easily for standard
privacy policies and things like that.
Also, you could look around on Android apps
for privacy policies.
But unfortunately, I don't, I don't think
we have one.
Not yet.
>>Nick: I found someone in my G+ stream shared
something just like that.
Creative commons privacy policies.
>>Richard: Well there you go.
>>Nick: Well, they're [unintelligible].
I can't remember what it says.
>>David: Well, isn't it also depending on
the content that you have in your app is the
type of privacy policy you have to have an
agreement to.
So it's very specific to your app, isn't it?
>>Al: There are some quite large encompassing
umbrella ones that basically say, "We're not
gonna share your data with third parties.
We're not gonna distribute it around the internet.
We're not gonna post it on our local notice
board."
Those kind of ones tend to be reasonably OK
for most things, but there are, there are
some complexities in it 'cause in certain
countries, you can't put into a privacy policy
certain things because you have to hand over
information to legal agencies and all the
rest of it.
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Al: It's tricky.
>>Nick: I'm trying to find the link that I
was talking about and share after this session,
but I will also caveat that no one here is
a lawyer.
So, don't take our advice.
>>David: Yeah.
>>Nick: Olympics amateur commentators.
>>Richard: Australians have just left the
traps.
>>David: As we know with all these patent
wars, they're evil.
>>Richard: Thanks for coming in today, David.
It's been great to talk to you.
Your questions as well and helping out.
Feel free to come back in any other time.
You're on the invite list now.
>>Al: And the interesting thing is the creative
commons' privacy policy is creatively commons
licensed.
>>Richard: Interesting.
All right.
Thank you all very much for watching today.
If you've got questions for next week, please
start populating the moderator and we'll be
back at 2 PM, GMT, next Wednesday.
>>Al: Thanks, guys.
Enjoy the cycling.
>>David: Thank you so much.
>>Richard: Cheers.
>>Al: Bye.